the video i just posted yesterday talked
about how apple's future arm-based max
will no longer come with discreet gpus
with evidence coming from apple's own
developer tutorial videos
but i keep seeing countless comments
saying that gaming is now officially
dead on the mac
with reasons ranging from the new
architecture
not being able to compete in the gaming
segment and apple silicon
not having enough graphics power without
a discrete gpu
and a lot of people saying that game
developers
now have no reason to make games for mac
anymore
but i've been digging through all of
apple's developer videos
and i've found something that apple has
never done before
that will greatly encourage aaa game
developers
to make games for the mac so i'm here to
tell you
that apple silicon is actually the birth
of gaming
on the mac but before we get into it be
sure to check out our new premium apple
product t-shirt
down below this video no apple silicon
macs are not going to support windows 10
using bootcamp
and they're not going to support
high-end nvidia or amd
discreet graphics apple will instead
have
a custom arm based cpu and gpu
built into one system on a chip or sock
basically one big chip now if you find
it hard to believe that they can achieve
enough power without a dedicated gpu
then you should definitely watch
yesterday's video
when this video is over but the most
important thing that people don't
realize
is that sony's upcoming playstation 5
and microsoft's upcoming xbox series x
do not have discrete gpus either
both the cpu and the gpu are on one
main chip on both of the most popular
gaming consoles ever
so if high-end game console makers are
switching to this type of technology
why can't apple and even if apple
manages to pull off great performance
there's still the problem of why game
developers
will finally decide to bring their games
to the mac and here's what i found
deep in one of those apple developer
videos for the first time
ever apple is opening up their metal
developer tools
to be used on windows 10 machines
and apple did this with gaming in mind
this means that large mainstream
game studios and developers that use
windows machines to create their games
will finally have access to create games
for iphone
ipad apple tv and the mac
using their current windows machines
previously a game production team
had to invest in apple mac computers for
their entire team
in order to create games for mac os and
because of that
there are services like max stadium
which allow you to rent a mac
from a server farm but that can get
seriously expensive
but now apple literally created a
windows installer
for their metal tools specifically for
creating apps and games for apple
silicon
that little piece of info came out of a
36 minute long video
that apple created which talks about how
to create
gpu binaries with metal which is needed
for gaming
and that long video includes a section
talking about how epic games was able to
optimize fortnite
using metal for the mac not only that
but they have multiple tutorial videos
focused on helping developers bring
their apps and games
to apple silicon max and the absolute
best part about these upcoming armbase
macs
is that they will natively be able to
run any ios
or ipad app so every single game or app
that you have on your iphone or ipad
right now will work on apple silicon on
day one just listen to this in mac os
big sur
we are leveraging this mac catalyst
infrastructure to enable running your
existing ios
apps as is on apple silicon based macs
here as is really means as
is we enable the user on the mac
to purchase or download through the mac
app store
the application you've already made
available on the ios app store
it is the exact same binary now you
might be wondering
how the heck will my touch based app or
game work on a mac
that doesn't have a touchscreen display
well here's the answer from that same
video
ios is built around a direct multi-touch
interaction model
but mac os is built around an indirect
cursor-based interaction model
the infrastructure automatically maps
many multi-touch gestures
and on the ipad side apple is finally
adding keyboard and mouse
support for ipad games which is a really
big deal
so if a game developer adds that
functionality then it'll automatically
be supported
on apple silicon max as well and to make
it even better
check out this quote from an apple
support document if your project
supports ios or tv os
it also supports apple family gpus
so basically if a game developer creates
a game just
one time using metal for apple silicon
that game will instantly become
available on the iphone
the ipad the apple tv and the mac
all at the same time and they can now
use windows to create it for the first
time ever
basically it is now about a thousand
times
more worth it to create a game for the
mac than ever before
since it'll also be instantly available
on every other apple device
the way i think it'll work is that each
device just has different ways of
controlling the game
iphones can use touch or game
controllers ipads can use
touch a game controller and now finally
a keyboard and mouse
the apple tv can use a game controller
and the mac can use either a game
controller
or keyboard and mouse and what all of
those have in common
is a game controller so the rumors of
apple developing one of their own
could actually be true since it makes
sense for apple to create their own
standard game controller to use across
all of the apple platforms
so i'd say that all of this put together
is more than enough to incentivize
aaa game developers to finally bring
their games to apple devices
thanks to it being much easier now that
they can do it using windows
and they only need to do everything once
for all apple devices
now you could complain that the switch
to the new armbase max
means that support for traditional pc
games is going away
and it is since bootcamp will no longer
be available
and they're ditching intel processors
however
it's been known that the pc gaming and
console gaming portions of the market
have been slowly declining while
smartphone
and tablet gaming has been growing very
quickly
and if you look at this chart the trend
is expected to continue
with 59 percent of the gaming market
being made up of mobile gaming
by 2021 and this is why we're starting
to see a
massive shift of high-end aaa game
developers
bringing their games to mobile devices
epic games brought fortnite to mobile
and made
one billion dollars in revenue in two
years
with just the mobile side of their game
blizzard brought hearthstone to mobile
and now the mobile version is making
more profit
than the pc version roblox mobile just
hit one and a half billion dollars in
lifetime revenue
nintendo brought pokemon go to mobile
devices and now it's made over
3.6 billion dollars in revenue and since
activision released call of duty mobile
less than a year ago
it's been downloaded more than 250
million times
for reference that's more than the unit
sales of every
non-mobile call of duty game that
they've made since 2007
combined in activision announced at
their last earnings call
that mobile is now the company's leading
platform
and looking into the future epic games
is currently working on bringing league
of legends
to mobile blizzard is currently working
on bringing diablo to mobile
apex legends is coming path of exile is
coming
and even bethesda's elder scrolls blades
recently launched on mobile the point
i'm trying to make is that
aaa game developers are starting to
bring their titles to mobile devices
because they see it as the future of
gaming despite the hardcore pc and
console gaming fans
which hate mobile gaming and every
single one of those popular
ios and ipad games that i mentioned will
also be able to run
on apple silicon max on day one
and since armbase chips are getting so
powerful
game developers are gonna be able to
bring incredible games
with high quality graphics to the mac
and yes
ray tracing is supported on apple
silicon
apple even made a developer video at
last year's wwdc event
so this is old news basically the entire
point of this video
is that apple switching to their own
custom arm-based chips does not mean
the end of gaming on the mac it's
actually closer
to the birth of gaming on the mac now as
far as when we should expect those apple
silicon macs
i think apple will have an online event
this october
where they will release the rumored
24-inch imac
probably a new macbook air and a new
apple tv
all powered by new arm-based chips
so hopefully you learned something new
from this video and if you did
go ahead and tap the like button and
click the circle above to subscribe
and be sure to check out our merch right
below this video
and definitely check out the video i
made yesterday right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one
[Music]